all right so we're getting things
popping for national caramel day
rocky theist is checking out a local
shop with over 50
unique flavors you can mix with your
traditional caramel popcorn
we've been celebrating national caramel
day for today and got a head start on
national caramel popcorn
day that is tomorrow here at popcorn
girl because uh i think
you've got plenty of caramel popcorn
here
what is this order that's right well
this is a giant order for a school it's
about 60 bags of popcorn they're going
to give to their teachers so that's
awesome for them
i love that but that's just one thing
that you guys can come in here and get
there is a whole plethora of unique
flavors though that popcorn girl has to
offer so let's talk about the flavors
you have all right well one of the most
popular i'm holding this giant bag of
denver
it's white cheddar and caramel mixed
together it's very popular savory
sweet and savory but we also have yummy
flavors like
lemon meringue pie cinnabon loaded baked
potato
mac and cheese dill pickle mac and
cheese popcorn yeah it's real cheesy
so if you love that you're gonna love it
and then people mix flavors together
also so you you can really customize
whatever you'd like when you commit
so tell me if you can remember maybe one
of the wildest mixes you've ever you've
ever gotten
white chocolate and southwest jalapeno
oh yeah
weird yeah but it's probably hot and
sweet
hot and sweet really good interesting i
hear the phone's ringing you guys got
orders going on
because you guys can order customized
gift baskets all of this so let's talk
about what's on the menu here when you
when you want to order from popcorn girl
well you can have any tin you want we
have usually every team
for sports for nfl we have lots of
college we have different gift baskets
we have birthday
get well we have all kinds of stuff i'm
sure easter was we do weddings
all of it we cater so just anything you
can think about it and call me i can do
it i love that so let's just talk about
popcorn girl in general what's the
history behind this great shop
well me and my fiance were vacationing
in the south and i noticed there were so
many confection stores
and i thought we don't have anything
like that and so we came back and
pop boom here it is there it there it is
so you have so much to offer here and
how can people order
people can either come in we have two
locations
uh west charleston and also out in north
decatur
and then we also can take online orders
or you can call
us and we can just deliver it we have
curbside just however you want it we can
do it
we ship nationwide nationwide look at
that and you guys are on the food
network now you've been on channel eight
yeah all those orders from the viewers
are gonna be coming in because
this popcorn is good guys i'm telling
you i'll send it back to you i might
even
bring a couple bags back if you're lucky
if you're lucky
wow okay all right guys so big question
of the day what is your favorite way to
have caramel
popcorn and chocolate candy maybe in a
sundae that's my favorite
david used in a sundae yeah i'm still
trying to figure out
is it caramel or caramel but i would say
i would say just you know straight up
the the regular stuff yeah
okay yeah a little salty and then you
got the caramel or however we're saying
it today
it's pretty good i like that baby here's
the deal i'm looking i'm picturing
vanilla ice cream
like you know plain vanilla but caramel
sauce
on top of that you know watching them
make it they had the little bit of
vanilla there
looked real good right i feel like you
could smell it through the tv
oh yeah well they said it taken it takes
an hour to make it would take us five
minutes to eat yeah
well rocky brought some back so that's
good another thing is you need to put in
a bowl and of course if you got a bowl
cut like
me and david did back man